the shadow work and pension secretary
jonathan ashworth is here with us hi
it's good to see you thank you let's
just start with savile given that that's
what we were just talking about um the
prime minister's clarified the situation
it's time to move on
well i mean
boris johnson was scraping the bottom of
the barrel wasn't he and the reason he
was doing that is because he's admired
in this massive scandal around these
rule breaking his partying the police
investigating
instances of rule breaking and i just
think it brings it back to the reality
that he's just unfit for office i mean i
mean
and how much longer are we going to go
on with this soap opera of tory mps
uh dancing around doing this hokey cokey
of whether they put letters in or not i
mean they just need to show up at a
backbone and get rid of him is it
appropriate though that carrie johnson
mrs johnson has found herself in the
firing line is that appropriate no i
don't think so
i think it is sexist misogynist
you know it's boris johnson who makes
the decisions it's boris johnson who is
ordering his tory mps today to cut the
pension in real terms it's boris johnson
who's ordering tory mps today to cut
support for families so they'll be worse
off by around 290 pounds for 10 million
families it's boris johnson who took a
thousand pounds away from families on
the universal credit it's boris johnson
who's imposing a 10 increase in national
insurance on working people so that if
you're on average earnings of around 30
000 pounds you're going to lose 400
pounds this year that comes down to
boris johnson not his wife so leave his
wife alone you know as boris johnson who
puts himself forward to the british
people he's he was the name on the
ballot paper not his wife leave her
alone you talk about the tax increase
their national insurance up by 10 but if
that doesn't happen
our already stretched national health
service is going to be stretched even
further
well i mean your previous briefing no it
wasn't my previous brief and you know
you've got six million people on the
waiting list hundreds of thousands of
people waiting to go up waiting beyond a
year for treatment can you imagine
waiting over a year for a hernia or a
hip replacement or cataract removal i
mean this is really desperate stuff and
it's a consequence of 10 years of
desperate underfunding in the nhs 10
years of failing to recruit the staff i
mean sergey javid he will come and sit
on your your program and you'll say you
saw because of the pandemic the pandemic
it's not because of the pandemic we went
into that pandemic short of 40 000
nurses with the highest waiting list on
record i used to come around
onto your show year after year before
the pandemic talking about the desperate
crisis in our nhs so that's why we need
the money from the national the nhs does
need investment it needs a plan to
recruit the doctors and nurses it
doesn't have a plan it does need a plan
to make use of the modern technology and
the modern advances that are coming down
the line in things like genomics we
don't have any of that we don't have any
plan needs last week we heard about
leveling up most poorer areas in the
country are areas across the north and
the midlands desperately underdoctored
not enough gps where's the plan to get
gps into our coastal towns there isn't
any grip from ministers on the future of
the nhs i'm going to take you back to
the national insurance so if we don't
have the increase in national insurance
where will the money come from in order
to fund the nhs and social care which is
a huge problem well in the end
government is about choices and they
could they could have made a different
set of choices in fact they could still
block this national insurance rise it's
not going to head yet and it's going to
be a 10 increase on people working
people are going to be really punished
by it torre and peace could still get
rid of this national insurance right
which when it comes because it's coming
at the same time as inflation 400 pounds
worse off someone average earnings of 30
000 pounds this is going to really hurt
but you can do other things you can tax
more fairly those who make their wealth
from stocks and shares from property
portfolios but fundamentally right what
we've got at the moment is this an
economy ran in such a way that growth is
too low and tax is too high and we're in
this trap
and unless we invest in the drivers of
economic growth in skills in science in
manufacturing then we're going to
continue with anemic growth and ever
higher taxes our tax is already a
70-year high it's because the government
just don't have a growth plan we would
put forward a growth plan to grow the
economy and from the proceeds of that
growth we could fund our national health
service our social care services our
schools our police but the government
don't have any growth plan what should
we do as far as nhs staff being double
vaccinated or out of a job
well given that uh um the the plan to uh
compulsorily vaccinate staff has been
abandoned they said they're looking at
it well i mean they basically abandoned
it because they knew they were heading
for a workforce crisis on it i mean they
say it's about omicron but it wasn't
it's because they have because they've
got sort of desperate shortages of staff
in the nhs i mean obviously we need to
get our staff into the nhs i would i
want to see staff vaccinated and i also
want to see staff take the flu vaccine
as well when that comes around but i
think in the way in which this plan has
been abandoned now you've got to focus
on getting the staff onto the front line
what about the staff that have already
lost their jobs in social care what
should happen to them well i mean i
think i think that should be considered
but and they should be allowed to come
back if if if they want to the bigger
problem with the staffing crisis in
social care where i think we've got 110
000 vacancies now it's because they're
not paid enough i mean
you're caring for you're going to find
the money for that but caring for your
uh loved one caring for your mum or your
dad who's got dementia should be a high
skill job and yet at the moment and this
is
not to knock people who work in
supermarkets not remotely
but actually you get paid more to work
in your local supermarket than to care
for an elderly loved one with dementia
that cannot be right we've got to pay
our social care staff properly we'd pay
them a national living wage at least no
money though
well i've as i said if you grow your
economy rather than accepting anemic
growth which uh the tories are accepting
we could fund social care but also by
the way was she soon that cause just
thrown away four billion pounds down the
drain to fraud billions has been wasted
on ppe that was never used i mean russia
sunak he's a bit like the bank clerk who
lets ronnie bigs in to clear the safe
and does nothing about it he's thrown
away billions if you have that 10
billion imagine what you could do for
pensioners imagine what you could do for
social care it's no good risky soon i
just say no it's four billion sorry i
couldn't do anything about it that's not
good enough yeah when we uh we were
reminded i think in the house of commons
just last week about when the
conservatives took over one of your
colleagues had left a note in the
treasury saying sorry there's no money
left yeah but it would be but
quite evidently was money because with
the government have been spending since
then it was a it was a joke probably not
a very good joke he wouldn't do it again
probably always regret but it was
clearly a joke there was money otherwise
government wouldn't have been able to
fund things for the last 10 years
so there was money
as far as um the well just just to say
as far as the treasury is concerned of
course we did hear from rishi soon act
last week during his news conference and
he said that they were clawing about
that money all the time so although the
headline goes to 4 billion that was
being wasted
and also when it comes to the ppe and
they it wasn't billions um they used 95
percent of what was available he's lost
billions of fraud as i say he's like the
bank clerk who just says to ronnie biggs
come in and clear the safe and does
nothing about it if that's just so bad
at what they do why is labour not as
effective as it might be why are you
losing position in the polls again is it
because you don't have a strong
effective leader no we do we have an
absolutely superb leader and i think
kirsten hammer will be the next labour
prime minister i'm absolutely convinced
of it and what you see later is doing is
unlike the government we're focusing on
families working people and pensioners
i'm highlighting the fact that
pensioners are going to be worse off and
actually if the government put in a plan
to drive up pension credit rates you'd
take hundreds of thousands of pensioners
out of poverty if government followed
our plan and imposed a windfall tax on
the big gas and oil companies you'll be
able to give people 600 pounds the
poorest people middle and those
struggling on struggling 600 pounds off
their fuel bills we're going to continue
to focus on the needs of working people
and families and pensioners who are
going to be hammered under the under the
current government because the tories
haven't got a plan to deal with this
cost of living crisis and just a final
thought on that 200 quid that we were
hearing about last week for to help with
your um with your fuel energy costs what
if you don't want it what if people
would rather not get it so that they
that don't have to worry about paying it
back over the next five years what
happens then i mean it's odd luck that's
the government's
is that your understanding because i was
trying to read into it and i thought
there's two problems
absolutely i mean from the government's
point of view it's like hard luck it's
tough cheddar cheese because if you get
it and then you have this 40 pound levy
imposed on you next year the year after
and the year after that and the other
bit of their plan 150 pounds it's not
even clear that the million pensioners
who are on council tax benefit whether
they will get it automatically or not or
whether they'll have to apply for it
well given that government can't even
get every pensioner to apply for pension
credit i've got absolutely no confidence
that they'll be able to get every
pensioner 150 pounds that that is due to
them so again pensioners who are already
making choices between you know not
having a shower not putting the oven on
because they want to save on their
heating bills impoverished further i'll
put that to the chancellor next time we
get to chat to him thanks very much
indeed thank you as always thank you